Wait a gentleman.
Black helicopters have been spotted.
Yes,
it's comedy.
Stop.
What the fuck?
You almost hospitalized me one time from laughing so hard,
like,
I don't know if you remember this.
I'm serious.
I even know if I could tell it.
It was,
it was backstage.
It was backstage at his show.
We were somewhere and you were like,
how's the way
you and I go,
you go,
where is she?
And I said,
I said some city in Tennessee,
maybe not or Nashville.
And you go to Nashville 96 and you started the story about working in a club and
you're like,
I just riffed in between shows some crazy shit.
Some chick who was talking.
There was eight people for that.
There was 20 people for the first show,
Knoxville.
It was a comedy zone show.
I have booked it.
Knoxville's a great little fucking town,
like a cute little Tennessee town.
It's like hip.
It's a football,
you know,
like a college town.
So I get down on Friday night,
Joe Rogan,
I'm headlining.
I got 38 minutes.
I just moved to La and I signed,
we creative management and they booked those rooms.
So they were booking me out as a headline.
I was just dying slope that,
so what they did was they put me in one nighters that paid like two 75 at night.
They weren't bad,
quite Tennessee,
you know,
and we'd go to this Knoxville for two nights and I go in there and you know,
made the,
I'm fucking crazy.
First one,
I go in there too.
Friday night there's 20 people for the first show and there's a girl,
Joe Rogan that's a 12 with a guy that's a fault.
Okay.
And it's her birthday,
you know,
meanwhile through it,
she just turned 21 it's her birthday.
Okay.
Hi.
Happy Birthday.
What's going on here?
You know,
because once you start hearing noise,
you would have to react with as a common and you're going,
what's going on here was 21 I said,
you're very beautiful.
And then she just went and ran with it and started talking about how a husband
pimps are out.
He would have fights on and for 20 bucks you could fuck her in the back room.
20 fights were on whatever.
I don't know that I'm Fridays.
He would bring it to the construction trucks.
Oh my.
You wouldn't bring a truck with her to the construction site and put a mattress
in the back and at lunch time that he would let her friends and she's telling me
this.
It's like she's talking and people like Mike just holding that breasts like what
is going on here?
This girl is beautiful and this retard is just pimping up.
So in between shows,
I go upstairs to do a line of smoke a joint or whatever the fuck I'm doing.
When I come back and I see her by herself,
when we started talking to them about what's going on,
oh my God,
I had such a great time.
I go,
what's that stuff?
True?
And she goes,
yeah,
go show me the monkey.
And she caught me in the woman's bathroom,
pull down the pants.
The girl had a monkey that was spotless.
It nearly stunk.
I ate it.
I find it a some.
And then she sucked my Dick.
That was it.
I went back to room.
I didn't think nothing of it.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
I go back for the second show,
there's eight people,
but by the time I go back for the second show,
Joe Rogan,
she's sitting in the back,
she's turning one and she's looking at me like this.
She's fucked up and 10 minutes into my spot set cause I was headlining.
She starts going,
I sucked the Comedians Dick Tonight and the husband was like,
what are you talking about?
And she's like,
I sucked his dick and he came in my mouth and he's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The cops had to hold him back and he's like,
I want my $40 that's all he wanted.
He didn't care that his wife Suck my dick at this comedy backroom.
Oh my God.
When the cops came,
he kept saying,
man,
somebody is going to get hurt if I don't have my $40 that's a $40 blow job.
Did you come in her mouth?
Because if I wouldn't have come,
it would've been like 20 or he cared about was the $40 dog.
So he told me that backstage at your show and I fucking started hyperventilating
$40 for his wife.
Okay,
this is the world.
Allow me,
ladies and gentlemen,
this is the world of crazy fucking calmly.
You think that's crazy.
Why she's crying.
Some of the Haggadah going to harm his wife and said,
you know,
Nah,
he didn't care.
He just wanted to $40 for a blow job.
I didn't give it to him.
He's got rules and he got to give him that.
He's got like a line in the sand.
This has got,
he's got not much.
These are fucking crazy animal.
When you sit at home at night and you think about all the Shit we've seen and
we've learned a lot,
I don't think I've ever laughed as hard.
Well that's probably the second time right there on that road.
We want to a lot of things.
You went a lot of things about human beings,
you and one of the things about an individual,
you learn some grabbing.
I did American home.
It's a,
uh,
armed forces place in Idaho.
It's part of the triple one.
And this one's like walked in and I had to go meet,
do a sound check.
Everybody kept looking at me going,
hi,
how are you?
Have you met sandy yet?
And I go,
no.
And they go and they can walk away.
You ever see a,
what's the movie with Eddie Murphy when he,
with Boomerang?
Yeah.
When he goes to the black chicks house,
it's the 80.
And the Butler keeps laughing.
Remember the Butler would go,
you have to,
she wants to see in the kitchen.
He would go,
because she knew he was gonna.
She was gonna rape him.
So every time some people would refer to as Shirley,
they go,
have you met Shirley?
And you go,
no.
And they go,
oh.
And they'd walk away.
Will surely,
whether the captain of that base was the head of the base,
she was his wife.
And if a band came to town or a comedian came to town,
she blew it.
That's it.
That was the rule.
Like he and he would sit out there with his fucking military arm and all his
shit and clap and she'd be in the back.
Sue mink cause the whole band.
I mean this is crazy.
So I didn't know about this.
She came over and started talking to me and then she started telling all your
Cuban,
I dated a Cuban one time.
He had such a big thick,
do you have a big thing?
I mean it was that quick list.
It was that quick.
Like she just gets to it.
She's like 15 I was maybe like 31 she was maybe 50 wow.
Cause she just dropped behind the curtain.
It took the hammer out.
I'm sitting there minding my own business and also somebody comes yelling for
Shirley,
Shirley.
Now usually surely we get up and stop sucking a dick.
Not surely she moved her knees like I had neon belly.
Right.
Then when somebody puts me on belly,
he's supposed to move this way.
Right.
That's what she did with her knees.
She kept sucking and just kept moving this way.
She,
I tried to take it out of her mouth.
She wouldn't let him.
She's like,
no,
no.
She,
she wouldn't stop until,
I mean,
and they're like,
Shirley,
if we out here,
man,
this is crazy shit.
I can't,
I'm overstimulated.
I feel like I need psychiatric treatment right now and Ivy fucking drink.
I love Maine.
Kiss.
His greatest thing anyone's ever said that is the best word of all mean gives
you Sukala mink
oil.
It's mean Kia.
But when they say Sukkah they cut it short.
What is the word?
What does it mean mean?
Gimme Suck my Dick.
Mika.
In a dilute the Sukkah mean suck.
Right,
okay.
You know,
it's so weird how the more banish this is Italian Sicilian really chill.
The deeper you go down to boot,
the more,
is it closer to Spain or is it farther from Spain?
The closer at Lee is from Spain.
When people from that area,
so to speak,
Italian,
I don't care how fast that talking,
they can't put the wool over me because I could pick up every fort worth.
Oh,
right.
So Sicilian say Sukkah what's sucking Spanish too?
Buh.
[inaudible] you were in the neighborhood,
right?
So cal,
I mean,
when they say sue MaineCare,
like,
like we,
well,
what are you going to do today?
I don't,
I'm going to go out and get it.
My Mika Suck.
But sue color main is just the short answer.
Hey,
that's your second shirt of this show.
So Columbia.
Sure.
And then you got minkya juice
comes at you where you want it.
Okay.